[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy Armenia Fernández por Andrés espinal
cuando el ejército ruso evacuó los
territorios ucranianos que ocupó en 2022
dejó detrás a miles de sus soldados
muertos desde entonces pequeños grupos
voluntarios ucranianos tanto militares
como civiles trabajan arduamente para
encontrarlos y devolverlos a Rusia
nuestro corresponsal guler crack
acompañó a uno de estos grupos en la
región de jarquín
máxime y jurista como es conocido tienen
que cruzar este terreno pantanoso porque
del otro lado está el cuerpo de un
soldado ruso
los dos hombres dicen que lo sostiene el
espíritu de cámara de día porque el
trabajo es abrumador recogen cadáveres
que se hayan a lo largo de la región de
harkheid después de un kilómetro
llegamos a Nuestro objetivo ya habíamos
venido antes y nos llevamos todos los
cuerpos que pudimos ahora volveremos por
el quinto como pueden ver no queda mucho
estaba herido tiene torniquetes en las
piernas Solo queda la mitad del cuerpo
la otra mitad probablemente se la
comieron los perros o se la llevaron
esperan que la opinión pública rusa
comprenda la magnitud de las pérdidas y
que el apoyo a la guerra disminuya
estamos dispuestos a hacer un
intercambio de todos los cuerpos que
encontremos por los nuestros y de verdad
les ruego a sus familiares Que organicen
protestas allá Desde luego el principal
objetivo de los hombres que recogen los
cadáveres es intercambiarlos por los
restos de los soldados ucranianos
sin embargo también buscan evitar la
contaminación medioambiental y recogen
pruebas que puedan ser utilizadas en
futuros juicios por crímenes de guerra
primero los llevamos a la morgue y una
vez identificados los subimos a los
vagones
en este vagón de tren hay una docena de
cuerpos de soldados rusos serán
intercambiados en los próximos días
qué siento hacia ellos
Yo nada
yo son cadáveres y ya jurista ya ha
recuperado más de 400 cadáveres rusos en
la región de jarquid todavía quedan
cientos por encontrar
la invasión estadounidense en Irak en
2003 también fue una amenaza para la
ciudad de Babilonia considerada una de
las más antiguas de la humanidad las
tropas extranjeras crearon una base en
las proximidades en las ruinas que el
excitador sadamjo y sein estaba
reconstruyendo Maki mohama de 56 años ha
vivido toda su vida en la zona y ha sido
testigo de los devenirs de este lugar al
que regresan los turistas después de dos
décadas Catalina Gómez Ángel nos cuenta
su historia
de tanto repetirlo Maki Mohamed memorizó
la inscripción que el ex dictador Sadam
husein ortegó tallar en los ladrillos
utilizados en la reconstrucción de la
antigua Babilonia en 1988 construyeron
esta parte más atrás fue en 1989
como lo hizo Nabucodonosor II
considerado el más grande de quienes
reinaron el Imperio Babilonia San José
se obsesionó con dejar su legado en este
lugar considerado cuna de la humanidad
construyó su Palacio en lo alto de las
ruinas a las que quería devolver su
grandeza
la nueva Babilonia duró 2.600 años Fue
obra del famoso rey de la nueva
Babilonia que empezó a construirla en el
año 605 antes de Cristo máximo estas
planicies y su familia trabajado en
Babilonia por generaciones su mayor
preocupación es la conservación del
lugar
muchos de los turistas iraquíes que la
visitan son extremadamente jóvenes y no
son conscientes de la importancia de
cuidarla pero su mayor dolor de cabeza
fue durante la invasión estadounidense
en 2003 las tropas extranjeras
levantaron uno de sus campamentos en los
alrededores de la ciudad estaban dentro
de la ciudad antigua había vehículos
blindados cerca del monumento del león
su aeropuerto estaba detrás de estos
árboles sus vehículos y soldados
tuvieron un impacto negativo en la
ciudad antiguamente
la razón para la detención fue pedirle a
una soldado que no se llevara uno los
ladrillos milenarios me ataron las manos
a la espalda y me pusieron una bolsa
negra en la cabeza me llevaron a su base
cerca de la puerta de Star y luego me
metieron en la cárcel me ataron las
manos durante aproximadamente un mes me
torturaron y eso me afectó negativamente
me presionaron los huesos me quedan
estas cavidades dos décadas después la
vida recuperaba una cierta normalidad
cada días visitado por más turistas
algunos de ellos extranjeros que poco a
poco vuelven a regresar para alegría de
Maki Mohamed Siempre listo a explicar
cómo era esa Babilonia una de las
ciudades más antiguas de la civilización
la semana santa es sinónimo de
abundancia en Guatemala porque atrae a
medio millón de turistas Sin embargo a
estos visitantes se les responsabiliza
por la escasez de agua que sufren los
habitantes de los municipios cercanos a
la ciudad de antigua Aunque la visita de
los foráneos dificulte el acceso al
recurso hídrico en esta temporada la
raíz del problema proviene de la crisis
climática del crecimiento de la
población de la falta de construcción de
nuevos sistemas de acueducto y de una
mala gestión Andrés Suárez y Aurora en
la historia
cada día
a primera hora de la mañana se repite la
misma escena en este municipio
guatemalteco
necesitan tomar agua los perros y no hay
agua seño qué hacemos
a 10 minutos de la turística antigua
está al de azufre como muchas otras en
los alrededores de cortes de agua
cotidianos que pueden prolongarse por
semanas quisiera uno tener el agua como
allá pero no y este panorama se tensa
aún más a medida que se acerca la semana
más importante para el turismo
guatemalteco para Semana Santa en estos
días por ejemplo se escasea más el agua
y me imagino yo como que desviaran el
agua para tal vez para la plazuela que
es la gente que hace mucho mucha venta
la alta vulnerabilidad de la región ante
el cambio climático perjudica aún más a
unos pueblos que históricamente han
contado con poca inversión en sus
infraestructuras
la producción de agua ha ido bajando es
un fenómeno y el otro fenómeno al revés
Es que la población ha ido creciendo por
su parte la municipalidad de
antigüedades cartas cualquier lógica de
privilegio del turista en detrimento de
los municipios no el tema de las aldeas
muchas veces es por tema de fugas en
algún momento puede romperse una tubería
lo cual puede pasar aquí también en la
ciudad cuando hay más por ejemplo hay
más eh turistas en las habitaciones hay
más consumo de agua muchas veces ellos
lo suplen con tienen pozos propios
algunos de los hoteles grandes la
carencia de una legislación así como una
red de acueducto que no sigue el ritmo
del crecimiento demográfico son en la
opinión de la población las causantes de
la escasez de agua en un país rico en
recursos hídricos como Guatemala
ya somos más de 1400 millones de
personas en el mundo cómo gestionar el
reto de la explosión demográfica tenemos
el ejemplo de bombay en la India donde
la población ha crecido 8 millones en 30
años por un lado prosperidad expansión
riqueza por otro los suburbios y en la
mitad una clase media que vive en
condiciones de hacinamiento nuestras
compañeras Angelique forget y Mary Boyer
de Franz 2 estuvieron allí y nos
muestran en este reportaje
tentacular y fascinante bombay la
capital económica de India ha visto en
los últimos años uno de los más grandes
crecimientos demográficos del país
más de 8 millones de habitantes en 30
años como si toda la ciudad de Nueva
York hubiera ocupado este lugar como
resultado el tráfico aumenta la
contaminación estalla y el acceso al
agua potable hace falta
[Música]
en bombay a medida que la población
crece los precios de los inmuebles se
incrementan a causa de una fuerte
demanda en ciertos barrios los precios
alcanzan los 10.000 euros por metro
cuadrado como en París mientras que los
más pobres la tienen más difícil para
encontrar alojamiento
a sus 52 años este trabajador social
vive con toda su familia en 14 metros
cuadrados
Esta es mi casa aquí vivimos ocho
personas mi madre mi esposa mi hermano
mi hermana su hijo y mis dos hijos y yo
una sola habitación está conectada con
una cocina minúscula y una sola ducha
los baños son compartidos con los otros
habitantes del inmueble
para dormir debemos arreglarnoslas Mi
madre duerme en la cama y nosotros
dormimos en el suelo unos al lado de los
otros quisiéramos mudarnos pero no
tenemos los medios para comprar ni para
pagar un arriendo
en la ciudad la presión sobre el mercado
inmobiliario es tal que incluso la clase
media tiene dificultades para encontrar
vivienda en el corazón de los suburbios
viven ahora ingenieros profesores
comerciantes
es contable gana mil euros al mes un
buen salario en la India pero que no le
permite abandonar el barrio donde creció
Este es mi hogar para él es imposible
comprar lo único que podría permitirse
era esta casa de ladrillo cada vez con
más frecuencia sustituye las casas de
Hojalata en los barrios de suburbios
no hay sitio para los más pobres ni para
la clase media dicen que en bombay
puedes alimentarte puedes trabajar pero
no puedes conseguir un lugar donde vivir
a pesar de la existencia de un plan
nacional que promete viviendas decentes
para los más desfavorecidos en bombay
sigue aumentando el número de viviendas
improvisadas casi una de cada dos
personas vive aquí en un barrio marginal
Hasta qué corresponsales de la semana
nuestro agradecimiento ancestral
panadería por cedernos sus instalaciones
para realizar este programa sigue con
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]